c'était il y a un peu plus d'un an
parkmouth était la ville la plus proche
du front que nous avons pu visiter
brièvement ceci est l'entrée principale
de la ville à l'ouest marqué par un
avion soviétique des années 50
les employés de la Ville plantent des
fleurs dans le terre-plein central un
semblant de vie normale juste à côté un
entrepôt détruit par une bombe russe qui
a aussi endommagé un immeuble
résidentiel voisin le reste de la ville
est encore intacte la ville fonctionne
encore à peu près mais elle est
pratiquement déserte il reste peut-être
le quart de ses 70 000 habitants dont
beaucoup de personnes âgées cette petite
ville du dambase avec ses avenues boisés
et ses immeubles anciens étaient réputés
pour sa mine de sel et son vin mousseux
produit avec des raisins de Crimée
à côté de la statue du héros cosaque
kindrate opasanovic c'est le marché
central la moitié des commerces sont
fermées surtout
utile aux militaires qui viennent faire
quelques achats avant de partir au front
cette fleuriste vend encore des fleurs
il y a des anniversaires et la fête de
Pâques mais elle ne sait pas si elle va
pouvoir rester elle a peur
un peu fanfaron s'est chauffeurs de taxi
jurent qu'ils vont rester ils ont des
bons sous-sols et de toute façon ils
disent qu'ils n'ont pas d'argent pour
partir
ont-ils pu tous partir sain et sauf
leur ville en tout cas n'existe plus
elle n'est plus que ruine ces images ont
été prises par des soldats du groupe
Wagner et diffusés à la télévision russe
certains soldats russes ont comparés la
prise de Dark mouta-ciel de Berlin en
la bataille a duré 224 jours le chef de
Wagner evghini Prigogine jubiles
nous n'avons pas seulement combattu
l'armée ukrainienne à la baffehmoud mais
aussi la bureaucratie russe qui nous a
mis des bâtons dans les roues les pertes
des deux camps ont été immenses mais
tout le monde conteste la valeur
stratégique du choix de Mahmoud
a très peu d'importance stratégiques
pour la Russie les Américains parlent de
plus de 100 000 morts et blessés
simplement pour une ville de 70 000
habitants en seulement darkmouth donc
c'est extrêmement coûteux pour peu
d'importance sauf au plan politique pour
montrer aux Russes que la Russie avance
qu'il y a qu'il y aura éventuellement
une fin à cette gare-là l'Ukraine a
perdu le centre de darkmouth mais gagner
des terrains dans les banlieues nord et
sud de la ville l'idée est de prendre
les troupes russes antenailles ça permet
de maintenir la pression dans les
régions de darkmouth lors beaucoup de
Trouper sont concentrés pour essayer
possiblement d'essayer de pénétrer les
fortifications russes ailleurs sur les
centaines d'autres kilomètres de la
ligne de France donc en gardant la
mobilisation russe ou dans la région de
Batman ça permet d'essayer de voir s'il
y a pas d'autres personnes qui peuvent
être faits d'autres endroits où il y a
plus de faiblesse une opération
audacieuse mais risquée les avants
ukrainiennes se font copieusement
pilonner par l'artillerie russe
Jean-Michel Leprince Radio-Canada
Montréal